- I do freestyle rap.
That is rap that's
improvised in the moment
based on your suggestions
on what you lovely people
would like to hear a rap about.
I asked the organization,
I said, "Why did you book me?"
And they said, "Well, we Googled you
and there was a review of you
that said your jokes were sometimes
more clever than they are funny."
(audience laughing)
I was like, "You realize
that's a bad review, right?"
And they go, "Not for
us. This is brilliant.
This is what we want, more aha than haha."
Because we are here to listen
and partake in a debate,
I will ask for a couple of suggestions
to be kind of molded that way.
So we've got some friends
and couples in the audience.
I would like to get a
suggestion first from a couple,
of a recent debate or argument
or disagreement that you had.
So if we've got any
couples in the front row
who are willing to share
a recent thing here.
You people here who,
you look both so handsome,
but it's also possible
you could be siblings.
That's how you are both 10 outta 10s.
You always gotta check, are you a couple?
- [Audience Member] Sure.
- Sure?
(audience laughing)
- So when your lady is that attractive,
you need to be more confident.
You need to be like, "Yes, yes."
- [Audience Member] Yes, sir.
- Yes. Thank you very much.
Yes, sir.
Gosh, it feels back over 250 years ago
when we were in charge.
(audience laughing)
What's a recent disagreement or debate
that you had with your partner?
- [Audience Member] She wakes
up at 4:30 in the morning
and then just does that.
- [Chris] Is that a bad thing?
That sounds like someone who's a CEO.
That sounds like you're killing it.
I love it. Okay.
A harmonious relationship except
for someone waking up at 4:30
in the morning. I love it.
Have we got some friends down here?
Friends are more willing to...
You guys pals?
- [Audience Member 2] Yeah!
- Yeah. Cool.
You are nodding more
enthusiastically than you, sir.
You're like, "I don't know. We'll see.
Depends if he's picking up the tab."
What's a recent disagreement
or thing that you've chatted about?
- [Audience Member 2] I
think we chatted about
like the US involvement in Ukraine
and what's the right level?
(audience laughing)
- It's a great topic to
rap about there, isn't it?
So, okay.
A couple where one wakes up at 4:30
and the US involvement in Ukraine.
Those are the two kind of touchy
issues that were going on.
One touchier than the other, I believe.
And let's get a couple more suggestions,
and these don't have to be related,
that they don't have to
be related to the debate.
Just be as creative and
fun as you possibly can.
So if you've over this end,
shout out nice and loud
so that we can all hear it.
- [Audience Member 3] Whoopee cushion.
- Whoopee cushion. Thank you very much.
Bringing some levity to the situation.
Middle of the room, what are
you guys gonna come up with?
- [Audience Member 4] Dragons.
- Dragons? Yes.
What's your favorite thing
about dragons, my friend?
- [Audience Member 4] Breathing fire.
- Breathing fire. Of course.
Yeah. Good.
And then let's move over here.
Finally, the final
suggestion from you guys.
What you gonna have a rap about?
- [Audience Member 5] Populism.
- Populism?
Yeah. You guys should
team up with them as well.
Be all, that's what we
want at the rap show.
Okay, so this is gonna be a freestyle,
as I said, a rap made up on the spot,
based on your suggestions on a
partner who wakes up at 4:30,
whoopee cushions, dragons
and how they breathe fire,
populism, and the US and its
involvement in the Ukraine.
Great, I know which section of the rap
is gonna be very short and brief.
So if we can drop that beat my friend.
This, as I said, a freestyle.
Are we gonna press play on that?
Yeah, there we go. Look at that.
That's what happens. The
crowd completely silent.
Just going, "This is gonna be
the worst thing we've ever seen."
It's not.
It's gonna be incredible and
it's gonna start with you.
Here we go.
♪ First thing, practical joke ♪
♪ How I start sitting down on the chair ♪
♪ Run ahead that fart sound ♪
♪ I'm like, oh no, a joke is near ♪
♪ On the whoopee cushion it
can say it's a Bronx cheer ♪
♪ Never understood what it means ♪
♪ As a young gun, as
a preteen I was keen ♪
♪ Playing all the pranks,
it's not my fault ♪
♪ I used to switch that
sugar shaker for salt ♪
♪ But the whoopee filled me with glee ♪
♪ It sounded like poo,
didn't sound like pee ♪
♪ 'Cause there's not a little noise ♪
♪ If you ask a whoopee cushion for pee ♪
♪ Would just be a splash ♪
♪ Or a puddle that starts expanding ♪
♪ Gotta get your air in
there, expand things ♪
♪ Then it goes pfft, that's the sound ♪
♪ Of when it deflates
when the thing goes down ♪
♪ Oh yes, I can break out
of the prison of the mind ♪
♪ Let me move onto populism all the time ♪
♪ People gather there in the field ♪
♪ I'm popular, but you start to feel ♪
♪ It doesn't mean that, it's
like some things maybe ♪
♪ Lead us there on the right wing ♪
♪ They're like, yeah,
we got a wild one on ♪
♪ Maybe shout out someone
like Tucker Carlson ♪
♪ Trying to appeal to a very large gang ♪
♪ Oh yes. I might not understand ♪
♪ Like my boy over here ♪
♪ He'd be like, sir, please ♪
♪ My lady wakes up early ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ Yeah, I'm gonna do her dirty ♪
♪ Alarm clock going off at 4:30 ♪
♪ Please make no mistakin' ♪
♪ It's fine if she's
cooking me eggs and bacon ♪
♪ But no, she's having some fun ♪
♪ She starts exercising,
maybe going out on a run ♪
♪ Does the jogging, keeping ever so fit ♪
♪ I'm in bed ♪
♪ I feel like a little lazy person ♪
♪ But when she comes back ♪
♪ I prank on her with the whoopee attack ♪
♪ Yeah, I put her on the sofa cushion ♪
♪ She sits down, pfft,
then she's blushing ♪
♪ It's ever so sad ♪
♪ Feels me pain, I got shame ♪
♪ Anyway, move on to Ukraine ♪
♪ Ah yeah, the fun stops ♪
♪ War going on, yeah ♪
♪ Some blocks start blowing up in Kiev ♪
♪ All the Russians, they be
like, oh we should leave ♪
♪ But then Putin, he be getting angry ♪
♪ Asks, no, I demand that
you're there in the draft ♪
♪ Off to the front ♪
♪ It's not a thing for comedy ♪
♪ in the US, maybe they
can do it properly ♪
♪ Put a lot of millions, billions, too ♪
♪ They're like careful ♪
♪ With this you could
have blew up some things ♪
♪ And it's out of order ♪
♪ If they attack over the Russia border ♪
♪ All hell might break loose ♪
♪ Look, I've really brought
the mood down for all of yous ♪
♪ But don't worry ♪
♪ One thing we admire ♪
♪ Dragons in the sky when
they breathe in fire ♪
♪ Oh yes ♪
♪ It never fails ♪
♪ You got the fun females
there with the scales ♪
♪ Going around ♪
♪ Yes, you can see them on HBO, on TV ♪
♪ That's how we end, not how we start ♪
♪ This spit fire like
the dragons, Dracarys ♪
(thunderous applause)